imagine how you'd react to the headline
mutated coronavirus discovered killing
30
of those infected
smallpox was such a lethal virus
estimated to have killed 500 million
people in its last century
but a massive international team effort
defeated smallpox completely eradicating
it and unicef estimates that this has
saved close to 200 million lives so far
today to celebrate the 41st anniversary
of the official eradication of smallpox
we grant the future of life award to two
heroes who critically contributed to
this victory
bill feige and victor zdanov
viktor's donov has been called the best
person who ever lived by oxford
professor will mccaskill for
successfully persuading the world health
organization to initiate an eradication
campaign where the united states and the
soviet union teamed up despite the cold
war
while serving as the soviet union's
deputy minister of health victor zjanov
persuaded naysayers both at home and
abroad that the world could and should
eradicate smallpox with a united effort
and arranged for the soviet union to
donate 25 million doses of smallpox
vaccine to kickstart the effort in
developing countries
the world health organization accepted
his proposal in 1959
and he lived to see smallpox officially
eradicated in 1979.
he passed away in 1987 and his award
will be received by his sons victor
zjanov and michael bukrinsky in his
memory
eradicating smallpox required not only
audacity but also solving the problem of
insufficient resources for vaccinating
everyone while working for the center of
disease control in africa as chief of
the smallpox eradication program
bill fakie developed a highly successful
surveillance and ring vaccination
strategy which has been described as
applying water to the house on fire
rather than the whole neighborhood
this greatly reduced the number of
vaccinations needed ensuring that the
limited resources available suffice to
make smallpox the first infectious
disease to be eradicated in human
history
bill feige and victor donov are true
heroes
who remind us of the power of science
and international collaboration for
tackling coven 19
and future health challenges
thank you both
[Music]